this week on trumped a member in the  White House gets voted out only the  Donald knew who it would be it was down  to rights Sean and Michael rumor had it  that Michael was on thin ice because he  had not been truthful with the real  authority in the house Mikey be easy d  kept it quiet all weekend building  suspense and cleverly playing dumb I  don't know about it I haven't seen  Donald called a house meeting to  determine who would get the boot six of  his friends voted mikey p Johnny Mad Dog  the Koosh ball bandman and writes the  bad boy the votes were tallied and the  big fat loser was announced publicly sad  the evolving and eroding level of trust  as a result of this situation in a  series of other questionable instances  is what led the president to ask for  general Flynn's resignation so long  Michael next week which lucky foreign  leader will win a dinner for two at the  fabulous beautiful grounds of Mara laga  you